today on the matt walsh show the media
specializes in spinning false narratives
but the narrative they've concocted
about border patrol agents on horseback
whipping and lassoing haitian immigrants
is perhaps the most absurd yet we'll
discuss that today also speaking of
those illegals shouldn't we be treating
the immigrant invasion as a biological
terror threat given that none of them
are masked or vaccinated we treat
unvaccinated american citizens that way
after all plus australia descends
further and further into fascism is it a
preview of things to come in this
country and facebook facebook conducts
its own research and discovers that
social media is deeply harmful to kids
it then did the responsible and ethical
thing and immediately swept those
findings under the rug we'll talk about
all that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
it used to be that only celebrities had
to worry about their private lives being
exposed you know you had to worry about
the paparazzi rifling through your trash
or whatever
but these days uh everyone has to worry
about that because everything that
you've browsed searched for watched or
tweeted can be exposed to third parties
on the internet
everything is now open for the public
potentially and that is why to keep my
data private when i go online i turn to
expressvpn
did you know there are hundreds of data
brokers out there who sold businesses to
buy and sell your data the worst part is
they don't have to tell you who they're
selling it to or even get your consent
one of these data points is your ip
address data harvesters use your ip to
uniquely identify you and your location
but with expressvpn my connection gets
rerouted through an encrypted server and
my ip address is masked every time i
turn
expressvpn on i'm given a random ip
address shared by other expressvpn
customers that makes it more difficult
for third parties to identify me and
harvest my data so if you if you like me
believe that your data is your business
then you should secure yourself with the
number one ranked
vpn on the market visit
expressvpn.comwalsh and get three extra
months for free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
welsh go to expressvpn.comwalls to learn
more it seems uh redundant to talk about
the crisis down on the border because
the border has been in a constant state
of crisis for decades but the overall
underlying crisis flares up occasionally
into what what may more technically be
described as i don't know a super duper
crisis and that's what we're facing
right now particularly down in southwest
texas in del rio
where thousands of illegal immigrants
have set up an expansive bustling
impoverished tent city of sorts this is
what the compassionate
quote unquote immigration policies of
the democrat party get you
they get you
shanty towns in the desert they get you
immigrant families living under a bridge
they get you a third world invasion
which ultimately harms both the invaded
and the invaders
they also get you slavery and sex
trafficking
they get you kids raped and killed by
human smugglers
this compassion brings all manner of
misery and death and suffering to
everyone touched by it on both sides of
the border
because this compassion is not
compassion at all it is total
abject indifference
this is why defending the border and
defending it vigorously harshly
with force if necessary is not only the
most just and appropriate policy
as it is the basic duty of our
government to protect its borders and
its people but it's also the most the
most truly compassionate
if you're actually concerned with
minimizing human suffering to the
greatest possible extent
and we all should be concerned with that
then you'll make sure that immigrants
know that the trek across the desert
will be fruitless there's no need to
come
certainly don't send your children
don't risk their lives or your lives for
this it won't work
that's a message of compassion
compassion both to the would-be illegal
immigrant
or the would-be child who's going to be
smuggled across the border
and also to your own people who live in
a sovereign nation and deserve to have
that sovereignty preserved and defended
this is a conversation we should be
having when it comes to illegal
immigration
but the media is not interested in that
conversation so instead as always they
change the subject they are perpetually
on the lookout for false narratives to
help them do that and yesterday they
found a very convenient one images began
circulating online of border patrol
agents on horseback
apprehending immigrants as they
attempted to storm the border
there is of course nothing at all
strange about this border patrol agents
are supposed to patrol and defend the
border it's right there in the name
border patrol and considering they're
out in the desert it makes quite a lot
of sense for them to perform this duty
on horseback
you see cops in major cities on
horseback so
and sometimes that to me
seems a little silly but
on the border in the desert makes a lot
of sense
but the images of
white looking border patrol agents on
horseback
and i say white looking because in fact
many of these border patrol agents are
hispanic
but the image of a white looking border
patrol agent on horseback rounding up
mostly black haitian immigrants and more
on the haitian part of this story in
just a minute
presented an opportunity to media
propagandists that they simply couldn't
pass up so it began with a guy named
sawyer hackett who providentially
actually has the word hack in his name
and he posted two images of the mounted
border patrol agents along with this
caption caption is
border patrol is mounted on horseback
rounding up haitian refugees with whips
this is unfathomable cruelty towards
people fleeing disaster and political
ruin
the administration must stop this
and now pardon the pun we're off to the
races the news was trending across
social media border agents are using
whips against haitian refugees
every major media outlet published their
own headline
these days a narrative cements and
metastasizes within minutes seconds even
that's all it takes
now used to take longer for a false
narrative that the media has always
perpetrated false narratives perpetuated
false narratives
but in the past it would take some
effort to get people to
believe it
um but now with the internet it just
takes a second
all across social media and the news
media people were breathlessly
condemning the evil officers who are
whipping and lassoing haitians down on
the border like some kind of old western
film
comparisons to slavery were made
the white house was asked about the
whips
and jen pasake though admitting that she
doesn't know the context
still said that the images are
inappropriate and terrible and even
horrific listen
i've seen some of the footage i don't
have the full context i can't imagine
what context would make that appropriate
but i don't have additional details and
certainly i don't have additional
context april i don't think anyone
seeing that footage would think it was
acceptable or appropriate
thanks so much jen um i want to follow
up on the question about haitians and
and
specifically these these photos that are
surfacing on border patrol agents
seemingly using whips i know you said
that there's no context that it would be
seen as inappropriate so the question
really is why would this be happening
under the side administration is this
going to stop what would the pro i i
wonder
sort of what are going to be the
consequences if what we're seeing is
what we're seeing
i mean yamiche it's all good questions
we just saw this footage um it's
horrible to watch um i just have to get
more information on it
april i don't i don't have more
information on it i've also seen the
video i can't imagine what the scenario
is where that would be appropriate i'm
certainly not suggesting that but we've
just seen the footage short earlier this
morning
i know you said that you're still
assessing it but just to add if this is
what we see is the is it the president's
stance or the white house's stance that
whoever these border agents are using
what seems to be whips on migrants that
they would be fired or at least never be
able to do that again of course they
should never be able to do it again i
don't know what the circumstances would
be it's obviously horrific the footage i
don't have any more information on it so
let me venture to do that and we'll see
if there's more to convey
yes i have no idea what's actually going
on she says but whatever it is it's
definitely bad these men down on the
border who work for us and are doing the
job they were hired to do
are clearly guilty of horrific
atrocities i don't know anything about
the situation but i know enough to throw
our own people under the bus that's for
sure
the white house showing more of its
trademark
moral courage with that response
but is it true that the border patrol
agents were using whips well the first
answer is that doesn't matter if it's
true the narrative is all that matters
the truth is irrelevant
to almost everyone who is propagating
this narrative
the second answer is that no of course
it isn't even remotely true city boy
sawyer was perhaps intentionally
misinterpreting the horse reigns for a
whip
that's what those ropes on the horse are
there they're reins
okay and uh if you've ever seen someone
on horseback and you've wondered how
they managed to steer the horse in the
direction that they want the horse to go
this is how they do it and that must
have seemed like a pretty
pretty weird magic trick
if you didn't know about horse reigns
they don't you they don't use animal
telepathy it turns out
they also don't jump on the horse and
say all right sparky take me wherever
you want to go
where are we going today
no they use these things called reins to
steer the animal in the preferred
direction
that's what those ropes are
but we know the left has long had
trouble dealing with ropes they they're
very scandalized by really a
any rope in any form they're scandalized
first they thought a garage door pull in
a nascar garage was it was a was a noose
i mean they thought a a rope hanging
from there for a like a tire swing in a
park was a noose they thought a a cord
at a cracker barrel was a noose
and now they think horse rains are a
whip
they seem to think that every rope is
somehow sinister i can only imagine what
would happen to these people if they
ever went into i don't know an indoor
rock climbing facility
whips and nooses all over the place they
probably think of some kind of bdsm
dungeon
so the second thought they'd feel right
at home i guess
but all of this talk of whips and nooses
obscures another more important point
we are told that the immigrant horde
being whipped quote unquote down in del
rio are haitians
now haitians i hope i don't have to
remind you
are from haiti
haiti i also hope i don't have to remind
you is not in mexico
or even near mexico it is an island
nation thousands of miles away across
the sea
the media is talking about these people
as if they're fleeing haiti itself which
would mean
that they'd gotten boats presumably
thousands at a time and sailed up the
gulf of mexico hundreds and hundreds of
miles docked somewhere on mexico's coast
and then walked through the desert
parallel to the u.s border only to then
convene around southwest texas and try
to enter there all at once
that makes no sense at all
there would have been many potential
ports of entry much closer and easier to
access i mean if you're taking a boat
from haiti and you want to get into the
u.s
how do you end up in del rio
so that doesn't make any sense
but that's the impression we're supposed
to have when they talk about well the
haiti they're fleeing political
persecution and so and so
the implication is that they are fleeing
haiti
but again that doesn't make any sense if
you're fleeing haiti you're not going to
end up in del rio of all places
so why are they there
and why isn't anyone in the media asking
this
why are we having to talk about horse
reigns instead of discussing the origin
and intentions of this mysterious mass
of haitians hanging out in del rio for
unknown reasons
now i don't have all the answers myself
i have the questions which is why i'm
asking them
but it does seem pretty clear that many
of these people probably all of them
are not coming from haiti at all
they were would stand a reason
already in central america somewhere
and probably had been there for years
now this makes it dubious to refer to
them as haitian refugees or haitian
asylum seekers if a haitian man moves to
guatemala and lives there for five years
and then tries to enter the u.s
illegally is he a haitian refugee
seeking asylum at that point i mean in
one sense
technically he's still haitian of course
but
the term gives a misleading impression
also why would we grant him asylum here
when he's already been living in another
country
he wants asylum from haiti right
well he was in guatemala why can't he
stay there
and if he's leaving from there he's like
he's got to cross other countries to get
to our country
but whatever we call
uh these
people whether haitian asylum seekers or
just illegal immigrants i tend to favor
the latter term
the question then becomes
and if they are leaving central america
why are they all leaving central america
and coming here now
why now why all at once
how do they all get there
why at that spot
these are valid questions i believe
questions worth asking
that again should be the first question
anyone in the media asks if they're
sitting at a press conference and being
told about a a tent city of haitian
immigrants
in del rio everyone should say what what
haitian immigrants why
nobody even asks it
nobody
well the media you know because they
don't want to talk about that
that's not a question they want to ask
because it's not it's not an answer they
want to be given
they'd rather talk about imaginary whips
and scary guys on horseback
they'd rather talk about anything but
the real point as always
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
we know that the left is in a constant
state of panic over everything but um
the panic over abortion especially after
the texas abortion law has been
certainly a site to behold
and uh it's i'm sure given you as a
pro-lifer many opportunities to talk
about this issue and debate it with
people but maybe you found during those
conversations that um you don't have all
the tools you need or you're not
equipped or ready to respond to the
just the rapid fire
uh
barrage of arguments that will be thrown
at you and that's why
uh you need to pick up the new book what
to say when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion from our friends at
40 days for life that's also why i wrote
the forward for that book which you can
read if you pick it up and it became a
bestseller uh the book did not the
forward i mean the forward's good too
and number one it's in its category upon
its release two weeks ago it's an easy
book to use it tells you what to say and
what not to say everything is uh very
neatly organized and so you can read it
from cover to cover as i did or you
could just you could go back and
reference it
flip the different chapters whatever
you're looking for it's all right there
from our friends at 40 days for life so
go to amazon or get it directly from 40
days for life at 40daysforlife.com
i also think it's funny uh
even if
those guys on horseback were using whips
which they 1000 percent were not
but even if they were
um okay they're using
a rope they're using a whip uh
against people who are trying to
illegally invade the country
they are in a place they don't belong
doing something that they shouldn't be
doing
um
it's just interesting to me that
the idea of using a whip is this
horrible atrocity i mean
you whip someone maybe give them a
little bit of whiplash or something they
have a little bruise there
that's a horrible atrocity
and yet the same people calling that a
horrible atrocity
even though for the fifth time it's
imaginary didn't even happen but
uh the same people saying that
also cheered
joyously with like tears of joys in
there of joy in their eyes
when um ashley babbitt
was shot in the chest and killed
inside the capitol building an unarmed
woman
okay in that case it's lethal force
being used on an unarmed person
and that's
yeah that's according to the left that's
not even sad they're happy
that it happened
and yet the idea of someone of like a
of an illegal immigrant trying to invade
the country getting a little bruise on
their arm from a whip that that
horrifies you the unarmed woman lying
dead with a gunshot wound is no problem
there
well of course here i am trying to make
sense and trying to you know uh
hold them to their own standards and all
like i said we know how fruitless that
is but i i did feel it necessary to make
that point in any case
um
we're going to get back to
some issues dealing you know related to
the illegal immigrant illegal immigrants
down there on the border in just a
second and we have to hear more from jen
pasaki unfortunately but before we get
there i think uh some
congratulations are in order to
uh canada
because justin trudeau was re-elected
yesterday as prime minister prime
minister of canada
so congratulations canadians you got
this doofus
for another term
i can't for the life of me imagine why
you wanted that
and i i i want to ruthlessly make fun of
you for this that you
what is this is his third term right am
i am i wrong
i don't pay very close attention to
politics up there in canada i've got to
be honest with you
but i believe this is the third time i i
can't imagine why you would want this
guy
for three terms
what has he shown you what has he done
for you
to demonstrate
competent leadership
i don't know how you could
live through that
being run by this
laughing stock of a man
and then say yeah i need some more of
that
and i want to make fun of you so badly
for it but then i realize
we have a dementia patient running our
country so i i can't even do it
and that's maybe the worst thing about
biden's presidency there are a lot of
bad things maybe the worst one is that
it deprives me of the ability to make
fun of canada to the extent that i
really want to
but i can still make fun of justin
trudeau anyway and here he is
i think this is after he was reelected
and he's talking about who knows what
he's talking about but this is just
funny let's play it
i will never apologize for standing up
for an lgdp l gt lbg
lgbtq2 plus
kids rights
to not have to undergo conversion
therapy
yeah you can't lgbt lgb lgb alg lgd
it's uh it is difficult
you know at this point to memorize the
entire alphabet soup
um
so you can't blame them for that very
much
what what what is the actual i tried to
look this up i don't even know what the
the acronym expands every week they add
a new letter to it so i'm not even sure
what the
full acronym is supposed to be now
and to me it feels a little bit
offensive because
now they sort of put the plus at the end
and that's supposed to cover all of the
other identities
so now i i guess the the official
acronym is
lgbtqia plus
and the plus goes for all the rest that
we're not listing
you know how to but how do they lose out
like that why don't they get they they
all have to be lumped together under
plus
and meanwhile you give q i and a their
own letters
we've already talked about the problem
with intersex so i the intersex they get
their own letter
even if they don't want it because
there's no reason for them to be
included in lgbt
in the lgbt label at all they've got
nothing to do with it that's a birth
defect um and then a is what a is
asexual
asexual these are people who allegedly
have have no sexual impulses or
interests at all
how do they get lumped in with people
who define themselves by their sexual
impulses
this is this seems like an entirely
opposite category of person
and they get their own letter and uh
they get singled out
meanwhile all of these other identities
they all get dismissed with a mere plus
i find that offensive personally
all right let's go back to the border
for a moment here
another question we might we might have
when we see these uh images
whether it's the quote-unquote
haitian refugees or any of these the
other uh immigrants trying to cross the
border
and you look at the footage of it one
thing you notice is that
none of them are wearing masks
and
we can assume that almost none of them
are vaccinated
so we're we are allowing
during as we're reminded
a deadly global pandemic
we still have thousands of people
unvaccinated unmasked untested
streaming across the border
uh jen pasaki going back to her for a
moment unfortunately she was asked about
this
by uh peter ducey who's the only actual
reporter in these briefings
and here's how she dealt with that
question about what's going on at the
border is somebody asking the foreign
nationals who are walking into del rio
texas and setting up camps on this side
of the border for proof of vaccination
or a negative covenant test
well first of all i can re
i can re-address for you or re-talk you
through what steps we take a policy for
people who fly into the country so if
somebody walks
into the country right across the river
does somebody ask them to see
their vaccination card
well let me explain to you again peter
how our process works as individuals as
individuals come across the border
and
they are both assessed for whether they
have
any symptoms if they have symptoms they
are the intention is for them to be
quarantined that is our process they're
not intending to stay here for a lengthy
period of time i don't think it's the
same thing it's not the same thing these
are individuals as we've noted and as
we've been discussed
we are expelling individuals based on
title 42 specifically because of kovic
because we want to prevent a scenario
where large numbers of people are
gathering posing a threat to the
community and also to the migrants
themselves so those are the policies
that we put in place um in large part
because again the cdc continues to
recommend title 42 be in place given
we're facing a global pandemic where's
the vice president on any of this isn't
she supposed to be addressing the root
causes of migration
absolutely and she has been addressing
the root causes of migration by working
with countries in the region to ensure
they have the assistance they need to
reduce the number of people who are
coming and trying to make those journeys
across the border we've actually seen
some reductions in some of those numbers
that doesn't change the fact that this
is a very challenging situation in del
rio we're working to implement our
policies and we're working to
ensure we are also addressing root
causes
okay now for a little bit of a fact
check there
fox let's go off to a fox report uh and
and here we'll see some of the images of
the uh immigrants
the quote-unquote asylum seekers
crossing
the river but also
um
we'll we'll get an answer to the
question of are we actually testing any
of these people as they come across the
border and it's a different answer than
what you might expect if you believe
what jim saki's telling you let's play
that
dhs secretary secretary mayorkas was
here today this is what the the message
he had for migrants who are considering
crossing take a listen
the majority of migrants continue to be
expelled under cdc's title 42 authority
those who cannot be expelled under that
authority
and do not have a legal basis to remain
will be placed in expedited removal
proceedings
and back out here live here's the deal
with title 42 yes most of the single
adult men in this camp will be removed
from the country sent back to their
country of origin uh via title 42. that
is not true however of the women the
children and the family units the biden
administration has not used title 42 on
family units so a lot of these family
units you see in here will have the
chance to stay in the u.s they will be
processed they will be released into the
country what's called an nta a notice to
appear in court for a court date
sometimes years down the road whether or
not they show up for it we got no way of
knowing we'll send it back to you and no
no covet testing uh going on down there
right right bill nope
nope
nope nope no vaccine mandates no
covetous just a reminder that the
president is going to speak at the u.n
tomorrow and one of his signature pieces
is how well kovet is being handled in
the united states and the importance of
that as his top issue
that his presidency is is undertaking
so no covet testing which which
we already knew that was the case
i mean this putting all the other issues
aside that we talked about at the
opening
which you really can't put them aside
but the basic duty of our government to
protect our sovereignty like that's
if you want to list the reasons why we
should protect our borders that that
should be the only reason that you need
to give
that's the only reason that any other
country needs for protecting their own
borders
that's kind of the mind-blowing thing
about this discussion is that
this discussion doesn't exist
in
any non-western country
some european countries it certainly
does
but i'm not aware of any non-western
country
that feels the need
to justify protecting its own borders
and they all do
and many of them use
much harsher force than we do
harsher even then a whip which is really
the reins of a horse
and there's no discussion about it
there's no real debate internally about
you know gee should we be doing this
should we be we have this border here
but
you know should we bother stopping
people from crossing it
there's no discussion about that
there are no other countries scolding
them for doing it
and the reason why every other country
on the planet at least non-western
country
defends their border first and foremost
and the only reason they would give if
they were ever asked to give a reason
which they're not
is that this is our country and it's our
sovereignty and we have to protect it
it would be a
bizarre question to even have to answer
um but if we're going down the list of
reasons there are the other reasons
that i said as well that this is the
most this is also the most compassionate
thing even for the immigrants
but on the
list is also the issue of covid and from
the left's perspective
this should be the only reason they need
for shutting down the border completely
by whatever means necessary shutting
down the border
because every single one of these people
coming in is a is a biological hazard by
their logic
by their logic these are essentially
biological terrorists coming across the
border ticking time bomb
they're going to spread disease and kill
they're going to they're going to kill
our grandmothers and our children
from covid
that's the less logic
that is certainly how they talk about
american citizens who are not vaccinated
and are simply going about their lives
that's even how they talk about children
who are unvaccinated
so that should be that that should be it
that should be if they're serious about
it
if they really believe all the things
they say about covet
and they take seriously all of their own
blustery condemnations of unvaccinated
americans if they took any of that
seriously and believed any of it
then it would be the left more than the
right right now who would be standing up
saying shut down the border we can't
have these people coming in
our grandmother's lives are not worth it
that's what they would be saying but
none of them are you may notice none of
them
all right um
i don't know maybe if some of these
immigrants end up uh
end up vacationing in florida
then they'll then they'll fit under the
umbrella of of people that the media
feels comfortable condemning i'm not
sure
all right late last week the pentagon
admitted that the
drone strike that killed those isis
operatives in afghanistan actually
didn't kill any isis operatives at all
and instead incinerated in entire family
three adults seven children were killed
here's commander general kenneth
mckenzie
addressing this and admitting to it and
offering
an apology i mean you tell me if this is
enough for you but let's listen
having thoroughly reviewed the findings
of the investigation and the supporting
analysis by interagency partners i am
now convinced that as many as 10
civilians including up to seven children
were tragically killed in that strike
moreover we now assess that it is
unlikely that the vehicle and those who
died were associated with isis k or were
a direct threat to u.s forces
i offer my profound condolences to the
family and friends of those who were
killed
this strike was taken in the earnest
belief that it would prevent an imminent
threat to our forces and the evacuees at
the airport but it was a mistake
and i offer my sincere apology
as the combatant commander i am fully
responsible for this strike and this
tragic outcome
well he's right about that
but he offers his uh oh i offer my
sincere apology
and that's all we're gonna get i offer
my sincere apology oh sorry about that
yeah we killed uh seven children
my bad
and then they move on and no one is held
accountable there there have been no
resignations over this
certainly nobody's been fired
and we've already moved on
can come out and admit now and say yeah
we did it we killed seven children
and a few days later we're not even
talking about it anymore
there's there's really no outcry no
public outcry anyway to hold anyone
accountable
i mean think think about
what you would have to do at your job to
get fired
it kind of depends on what your job is i
mean if you're a public school teacher
then then you'd have to do quite a lot
to get fired and probably then you still
wouldn't but that's government i mean
outside if you if you work outside of
government i guess i should stipulate
what would you have to do what kind of
mistake would you have to make on the
job
to get fired it probably wouldn't take
much
i know for me i could walk out there
right now and get fired if i wanted to
i could do it in like 10 seconds
the sky's the limit if i decided i want
to get fired i wouldn't in fact i could
do it right here on air
get myself fired uh and that's the case
for anyone who live who works outside of
the government you wouldn't have to do
much to get yourself fired and i and you
know you also wouldn't have to kill
seven kids
probably if you killed just like one
person
in your job
outside of government
and outside of the pharmaceutical
industry now we have to stipulate as
well you get fired
but in the government you can
directly murder 10 people including
seven kids
and still have a job
at the end of the day
that's the government for you
um kind of on the same topic here moving
on and over to australia as we know
full-on fascism has come to australia
here is uh footage that's
all the footage we see out of australia
is it just sends chills down your spine
um here's a law enforcement official
showing up to somebody's house
because she allegedly posted on social
media
that she would be attending a protest
potentially that's the allegation that
she posted something on social media
about going to a protest
and next thing you know there are
multiple looks like there's one on
camera but multiple law enforcement
officials at her house
talking to her about this let's listen
to that
sure okay all right is there a reason
why you're recording me today yes for my
protection
do you think i'm going to assault you or
something no um
so
i don't understand why you're here
and i haven't even spoken to you and you
think i'm going to
do something to you well we have seen a
lot of police violence in recent times
towards the public and there is a
growing
there is a growing mistrust i as you can
understand um
yeah not here do anything like that all
right let's go we're here to have a chat
to you because we have instructions that
um you've been posting some things on
social media
and
that you
got a protest protest on tuesday
um there's no protest on tuesday
there isn't okay that's fine but what
i'm here is to remind you to ensure that
you need to stay at home in relation to
covert
and um stay-at-home orders and if there
is or is not a protest on tuesday
regardless you still can't leave and go
to a protest of any sort i understand
and this is what fascist this is what
tyranny looks like when it actually
comes to it comes in the form of a
woman in a pant suit saying she wants to
have a chat with you
and she's very polite about it
she even said both the the it was a
little hard to hear there
but both of them said to the woman that
was filming oh we're not here to assault
you don't worry about that you're
perfectly safe
you just have to stay home
just stay in your house don't ever leave
your house and you'll be fine
of course if you leave your house we
might knock you down and
uh
spray bear mace in your face
cart you off to prison some of the
footage we've seen in australia has
shown that
but stay in your house and you'll be
safe
we'll make sure you're taken care of
we'll make sure you have all you need
just stay here and never leave
that's all we want to chat about today
but the really worrying thing the whole
thing is worrying um but
you have to wonder how did
these
whoever they are these law enforcement
officers
how did they become aware of this
alleged social media post from this uh
from this woman
and we could be sure the government is
monitoring all that stuff and maybe they
saw it on their own but more than likely
someone else snitched
you know some other citizen saw maybe
her friend on facebook or whoever saw
the post on facebook and alerted the
authorities
and sent the authorities to her house
and the person who snitched knows
how that could go
she might end up getting going to prison
she might and she might end up getting
assaulted we've seen the footage we know
how
the australian authorities are handling
this and that's what worries me the mo
this entire time that's what's worried
me the most
in australia and also here
it's been the most depressing aspect of
all of this
because if this was a simple matter of
us against them
you know the people against the
government we're all
in this together as we're
constantly told and
our our government uh
rulers are
oppressing us and we're we're coming
together under that oppression to resist
it like if that was the story
then it would be far less
distressing than what's actually
happening which is
you know the government is oppressing us
with the help of our fellow citizens
who are eager
to
become little tattletails
reporting not just
citizens reporting businesses
even though they're not you know the
person doing the tattletailing they're
not in any
great risk they could just continue on
their day
but they see the an opportunity to imp
through through the force of government
to kind of use the force of government
by proxy to impose themselves
on their fellow citizens
there are a lot of tyrants who have come
out of the woodwork
during covid and not just in government
a lot of people who
have been given this power to impose
themselves on others and they
that's a power that they they can't
forgo
they can't pass that up they can't pass
the opportunity up here's something uh
funnier than it is enraging two people
on a plane
very upset and worried that the guy next
to them has dared to take his face mask
off let's play a little bit of this so
the guy's uh
he's sitting on a
a plane i'm not sure which airline this
is go ahead and play he's sitting on a
plane and um
he's eating a candy bar he's got his
face mask turned up and then you've got
these this older couple sitting next to
him
and they've got visors and face masks on
[Music]
and now the woman is huddling in fear
covering her face
because this guy's eating a snickers bar
next to him
while the husband in the window seat is
shouting over
you're putting our lives in danger
they've got visors
face masks you know you know they're
vaccinated on top of it
and we go back to this irony of they've
got all of that and they don't trust any
of it
they have such little faith in the
measures that they themselves are are
taking here
that they think they might be killed
because a guy next to them is eating a
snickers bar
[Music]
and yet they're on
i think this is great
okay and yet they're on the plane
that's will continue to be the
mind-boggling thing to me
difficult for me to understand
psychologically i can understand the
virtue signaling
and something when you see people
walking around with visors and face
masks
oftentimes they're accused of virtue
signaling
and we know that virtue signaling is an
empty gesture where you're trying to
broadcast to everyone how seriously
you're taking this
uh and and i believe that there's that
there's certainly some of that going on
but the people going to that extent with
the visor and the face mask that's not
virtuous signaling they really are
terrified
the people driving in their car
at night with a mask on they're not
signaling to anyone this is
their brains are broken they are that
terrified and that's why they're wearing
it
and yet they're still on the plane
if you are that
worried if you're that afraid
that you think even with a mask advisor
and a vaccine you might be killed
if somebody takes their mask off next to
you to eat a snickers bar
for 45
seconds if that's how you feel about it
why did you get on the plane
because i guess i could only use myself
as a reference here and i know that for
me
if i really believed
that um
if i walk outside of my house
if i sit next to somebody eating a
snickers bar even with a mask on
that there's a very good chance that
i'll die
if i was that worried about it i
probably would just stay home i don't
think i would leave my house at all
the people walking down the road with a
mask on they think that that simply
walking alone outside without a mask
they might die that kovid might drift
over on the wind and make it into their
nostrils and kill them
and again if i thought that
i i just wouldn't leave the house at all
yet they they they still leave and they
want to participate in society and do
all these normal things
and yet they get angry at other people
who are trying to live their normal life
so it's all kinds of confused doesn't
make any sense at all all right let's um
let's say one other thing here let's get
away from the politics this is also
important for the new york post it says
a russian mma fighter dubbed popeye
because of his massive biceps has been
warned there he is there look at that
he's been warned that he might die if he
doesn't get the lumps of petroleum jelly
removed soon so this guy his name is
karil tereshin 25
former soldier
he injected petroleum jelly into his
arms and uh made those biceps
and now he has to get the lumps of
petroleum jelly taken out of his arms or
he might die
and i don't know it's just a really sad
story
i'll tell you what makes it sad
um the fact that this man has been
pressured into conversion therapy like
this
i mean he identifies as a big muscled
person that's how he identifies he
identifies as popeye
a big muscle person a bmp we call him
that's his truth that he's trying to
live
and yet he's being told he has to go
through this medical
deconversion
i i find it very upsetting personally
let's move on now to reading the youtube
comments this is uh from someone who
says
matt if you want to watch a good movie
with your wife then watch the courier
it's great you can ban me if you don't
like it i did actually watch that one
and uh that's the benedict cumberbatch
one right
and yeah that was that was pretty good i
don't know if i'd call it great
oh wait we've got oh we forgot to play
the song let's play the song go ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay good i can't believe i i i forgot
that i was gonna i was gonna
pass right over the sweet baby gang
anthem i should be canceled for that
anyway the courier is a good movie it's
i wouldn't call it a great movie though
i haven't seen um
i don't think a really great movie has
been made in several years i can't
remember the last
movie i've i've seen that was uh made
over the you know last two or three
years that was that would that truly
qualifies as great
and you know one thing about what makes
it a great movie is that it's great
movies are are rare by definition that's
why they're great
but uh
even so it's been quite a drought
i've seen a lot of uh i've seen i've
seen
several b plus b minus movies there have
been a lot of d's
a lot of c's d's and e's
i haven't seen a great one
uh let's see another one says matt when
the commenter said the divorce of the
usa would be the kid's fault
he was comparing it to the founding
fathers everyone alive today in america
would be the kids in this analogy
oh that would make sense you're right
that would make more sense than how i
interpreted it now i feel stupid
and for making me feel stupid you are
banned from the show
the real bridget says
you said the mask that masking kids uh
the masking the the kid video gave you
ungodly rage i think the term you're
searching for is godly rage i think
you're probably right about that
um
mattoo says what's the biggest
smallmouth you ever caught i don't know
i don't i don't fish for a lot of small
it's usually largemouth and the biggest
large mouth i've cost caught is uh seven
eight pounds
i've never gotten up into the double
digits small mouth i don't know not not
very large three pounds maybe
um
live cruelty free now says just when
matt says something sensible and
seemingly sincere about his personal
lack of concern or connection with
animal rights the juvenile all pandas
must die thing comes up again
why do men who want to come off as macho
or overtly masculine think it's so cool
or impressive to act totally indifferent
and flippant about animals hint it's
just it just comes off as juvenile and
insensitive well you seem to be under
the impression
that i'm joking about the panda thing
but
i don't tell jokes
especially not about this issue it's not
a joke at all i'm 100 serious
i'm sure that won't make you any less
outrage but
that's the fact i tell you what living
in biden's america might really make you
feel like it's aging you and that's why
you should turn to our friends at
genusal serum from chamonix if you're
one of the millions of americans male or
female who deals with bags and puffiness
under the eyes
that's why you need genus cell serum
from chamonix and cell serum uses plant
stem cell technology to promote visibly
healthier skin and the appearance of
younger healthier eyes genusel's state
of the art technology will become your
most powerful weapon against under eye
bags and puffiness customers everywhere
have been raving about this product
susan from new jersey wrote i've been
using genusell for a couple of months
the puffiness around my eyes is gone
which is great for susan now she'll stop
horrifying and terrifying her loved ones
and everyone who has to stare at her
face
not only that but my assistant tessa has
been using jen yourself for a couple of
weeks now and loves the results you're
seeing i've been gabbing with her about
genusl and she absolutely adores it with
its instant effects you'll see results
in the first 12 hours or your money back
they guarantee it so order now and save
big on genusel's risk-free introductory
offer all orders are up to fifty percent
off go to genusell.com and enter mat30
for an extra thirty dollars off today
and wait there's more we all predicted
the buying administration would be a
disaster but i don't think any of us saw
them descending into full-on
authoritarianism authoritarianism less
than a year into our dementia riddled
leaders reign actually i did kind of say
that but a lot of people didn't
and you know they've declared war on
businesses with over 100 employees
required that they force mandatory
vaccines or weekly testing for covet
that includes the daily wire but we are
fighting back and potentially facing um
the penalty which is 14 000 per
violation which can really rack up uh
but we're not going to back down to that
and we're not going to comply with it
and we need your help in fighting back
and the best thing you can do is go to
dailywire.com subscribe and use code do
not comply at checkout for 25 off a
membership and you can join us in this
fight
we need you please do it dailywire.com
subscribe use code do not comply for 25
off all right let's get now to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so you know my oldest kids the twins are
eight years old and more and more i'm
noticing something about them that seems
increasingly unique among their peers
but shouldn't be
and that is that my eight-year-olds
act like eight-year-olds they are naive
and innocent and energetic they like to
play imaginative games they like to run
around outside they love books
my son especially loves huck finn and
tom sawyer and you know he loves those
characters he'll run around the yard and
overalls and bare feet pretending that
he's on some great adventure
a little while ago all the kids built a
raft out of logs so that they could
float down the mississippi river even
though we don't live anywhere near the
mississippi river but still they wanted
to build the raft um
my daughter plays with dolls still she
likes to dress up in costumes she likes
to sew and make different kinds of
crafts she she last week she made
herself a dress out of an old blanket
um actually might have been a new
blanket that my wife just bought and she
cut it up and made it into a dress but
that was fine
now none of this information is
terribly fascinating or special i mean
they're just kids being kids right
very gender stereotypical kids too which
i know makes me an extremely
unenlightened parent and i'm fine with
that
but i've noticed that a lot of kids
their age
not all certainly but a lot
aren't like this
many kids these days at eight to nine
years old
don't have
the same kind of energy or creative
drive or the desire to run around
outside all day
this isn't just my own anecdotal
observation either lots of research has
shown that many kids they aren't playing
the way we did when we were kids
they aren't running around outside
they're not reading books they're not
playing physical or imaginative games
and there are many societal factors
which may help explain this shift but
the biggest one
without question
is that many kids today are living out
their childhoods inside a digital world
the single greatest factor that explains
why my kids seem a bit different from
some of their peers is that my kids
don't play video games
they don't have phones
they don't use the internet
we're not living off the grid in the
forest either though i kind of wish we
were i mean nothing nothing wrong with
living that way
we're living a pretty normal life for
better or worse except that our kids
don't have video games and they don't
use the internet
there are plenty of parenting decisions
that i have made that i later questioned
or second guessed but this is definitely
not one of them
my wife and i decided early on that we
would force our kids to have a real
childhood we're not going to give them a
choice in the matter
you can't give a kid a choice in this
because if you give them a choice
they're going to choose the tv and the
internet and everything else i mean
every kid's going to choose that if you
let them choose
so for us there is no choice
a childhood full of imagination and
physical play and scrape knees and all
the rest of it that's what they're going
to have and so far they've had that kind
of childhood because we're keeping them
away from every screen except the one
single tv we own which is in our living
room and which they're allowed to watch
for limited periods of time
and uh and of course only shows that we
approve of ahead of time i thought about
this today when i read a report
revealing how facebook which owns
instagram
has for a long time been aware that
instagram is harmful to kids especially
girls
the tech giant apparently conducted its
own research into the effects of social
media on the developing minds of kids
and they found that the effects are
rather dire social media the focus was
on instagram but this holds true across
the spectrum
social media for kids causes anxiety
depression body image issues
lower life satisfaction and so on and so
on and so on
makes kids lonelier
makes them more depressed it makes them
unhappier
now facebook knows this and and this is
the research they did
again that's not the only research on
this topic
this this has been studied
again and again again and again and
almost all the research you'll read will
tell you this
and facebook knows it but they swept its
own findings their own findings under
the rug which has drawn comparisons to
the big tobacco companies that
discovered a link between smoking and
cancer decades ago and didn't tell
anybody about it and i think the
comparison is apt though if anything it
undersells the problem
this is going to sound extreme and maybe
it is but i would rather my kids smoke
cigarettes
than spend all day on the internet
because the damage done by the latter is
that deep and that profound
our kids are being fundamentally changed
they're being turned into different
sorts of people worse sorts of people
because of their overexposure to screens
they're not learning how to be authentic
people or how to live an authentic human
life
many kids today simply do not know how
to find joy or happiness or fulfillment
outside of the screen
though they can't really find it inside
the screen either so they just don't
have it at all
and that's why
when i hear about what facebook has done
to cover up the damage its own product
does to the people who use it
i don't blame facebook primarily
i mean they obviously deserve 100 of the
blame for the things that they're doing
but there's another 100 portion
that can be assigned to parents
look i understand that at a certain age
it might be difficult to keep your kids
away from the internet
it's it's different when a kid is 16 or
17.
but parents today are giving their six
seven eight-year-olds phones with
internet access
that's what parents are deciding to do
and they can't use the excuse of well i
want my kid to have a phone in case he
needs me in case of an emergency
even that is pretty extreme
like the idea that your kid needs to
have this constant connection with you
all of the time
no kids in history had that i didn't
have that when i was a kid
i didn't have a phone where i could call
my parents at the drop of a drop of a
dime
and and you know i survived it was okay
but if you do want that for your kid
you you could you can buy them a phone
that doesn't do anything but make a
phone call
and you can make it so that it only can
call two numbers you know
your house phone and your and your cell
phone if you actually still have a house
phone or whatever i mean you can decide
so you can give your kid a phone like
that that's one thing
but there are parents who say you know
what no no i'm gonna give my kid
my eight-year-old
a phone with full and complete internet
access
and i'm gonna let them have it all the
time
it it's it
just
blows my mind
do you know how you can keep your
seven-year-old off the phone here's how
you do it real easy
don't give him one
it really is that easy
for a seven-year-old for a 17 year old
it's different for a seven-year-old
that's all you got to do
because they can't have anything if you
don't buy it for them
how does your child your young child
benefit from having the internet in his
pocket 24 hours a day what are the
advantages
i mean make a chart and list them list
all of the advantages to your seven or
eight-year-old having 24-hour access to
the internet
you know in what ways has his life in
existence enhanced by spending almost
all of it online
and go ahead and write all those
all those advantages down
now go to the other side
list the negatives
in what ways can he be harmed what are
the downsides
and then when you look back at the chart
which column has more bullet points
and it must be the negative column
because i can't actually think of one
single genuine advantage to an
elementary schooler having a smartphone
and yet millions of parents make this
choice for their children
and they and then they blame the social
media companies
for the harm that they the parents have
intentionally exposed their children to
maybe think of it this way
imagine a parent
who keeps their kid away from the
screens doesn't give him a phone doesn't
let him spend five hours a day playing
video games and so on
now imagine that parent sitting at the
child's high school graduation
do you think that he sitting there in
the stands is going to look back on his
son's childhood
reflecting nostalgic and say man
i wish i'd let him spend more time
staring at screens
do you think any parent who makes that
choice will have that regret
we all know the answer
and we all also know that many parents
will regret and already have regretted
allowing the internet and the media
and video games and everything else to
consume their children shape them mutate
them dominate their lives
and that is why today it is not social
media that i'm canceling it's not
facebook
but parents
who allow their kids to use social media
in the first place they're the ones who
are canceled and we'll leave it there
for today thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike cormina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
the san francisco mayor violates her own
mask mandate and she gives an incredible
excuse as to why she did that the white
house explains why you need to mask up
and backs up but the thousands and
thousands of illegal aliens crossing our
border do not and three black women beat
up an italian restaurant hostess in new
york city over the city's vaccine
requirements check it out on the michael
knowles show